- So, let's talk about
your new show though.
It's called "The Endgame."
So what's it about?
'Cause you play a badass. I like it.
- You know, FBI agents
are very specific people,
and, you know, God love them,
because you have to put
your country and your job
pretty much before anything
and everybody else.
And they do that for us.
They do that to keep us safe.
You know, the Armed Services, the CIA,
the FBI.
- But the sacrifice
for the family has to be hard.
- It's hard. It's really
hard for them, you know?
And so, it's an honor to be
able to go into that world.
And obviously, this is a heightened
and explored version of that.
There's this, I call her
this sort of Carmen Sandiego,
criminal mastermind.
- Oh my god, I love that
you said Carmen Sandiego
(Ryan laughing)
- Where in the world is she?
- Right?
She's on our show. We found her.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- And she's lovely, and she's on our show.
You know, it's like, who's bad?
Who's not? Is she bad?
Is she not?
Is she like working for greater good?
Is she only working for herself?
And I'm the only one that
actually has any intel on her,
so I become the sort of centerpiece of-
- [Kelly] The go to.
- Yeah, of this investigation.
- That's so fun. What a cool show.
- It's a really cool show.
- [Kelly] Yeah.